Peter Brown here with a gamespot news  update earlier today the Chinese  government announced its censorship  policies for video games a ban on video  game consoles has been lifted earlier  this year after 14 years all games sold  must be approved by the Shanghai  government culture department including  all dlc here are some of the violations  that will get a game banned in China  anything that violates promotes  obscenity drug use violence or gambling  anything that violates China's  Constitution threatens China's national  unity or integrity or otherwise talk  [ __ ] about China in any way hey you got  kid all this shitty chicken you can  carry or anything that breaks any other  law ok so i guess this episode is gonna  be banned in china then for all your  chinese video game related news stay  tuned to gamespot com